elle avait remporté le titre mondial
groupe improbable nom masculin qui est
curieusement parvenu à briller dans un
domaine qui n'a rien à voir avec la
cuisine je vous entends j'ai donné mal
de gens virés rivaux que toute cette
énergie négative s'évacue ouvre les
jambes elle va sortir plus vite pour que
c'est comme ça tous les ans un concert
est organisé pour soutenir les troupes
en europe
je suis calamity nous voici serenity et
charrie les six mois j'entrais dans le
groupe ge pourrait être obesity n'a
jamais affronté des groupes qui ont des
vrais instruments alors c'est quoi ton
elles ne sont pas à la hauteur des
autres groupes qu'on est pas des bouts
fans de service tu es bien sûr est ce
que je t'ai déjà lâché bien deux fois
pour tes pas du tout fiable c'est une
seconde nature pour toi ce sera notre
dernier concert ensemble alors qu'une
fille le musée exceptionnel groupe de
femmes vous aime vendre et or die
façon à la carte